el sonido de los disparos resonaban
mogadicio
mientras deja listas asaltaban el hotel
hyatt en la capital de somalia
el asalto inicial tuvo lugar el viernes
por la noche y último en la mañana del
sábado mientras las fuerzas de seguridad
luchaban contra los atacantes el grupo
extremista islámico al shabab ha
reivindicado el atentado
el grupo yihadista lleva 15 años
perpetrando atentados en somalia
continuamente en 2011 fueron expulsados
de mogadicio pero todavía controlan gran
parte de las áreas rurales del país y
con frecuencia atacan la capital uno de
los sucesos más mortíferos el atentado
suicida con un camión en 2017 en el que
fallecieron más de 500 personas el
último se produce en la misma semana en
que eeuu anunció la muerte de 13
combatientes de al shabab en una
ofensiva aérea y es el mayor ataque en
mogadicio desde la posición del nuevo
presidente de somalia hassan sheikh
mohamud hace tres meses